foreign
let's go ahead and hop on the call let's
go to Simone in
San Diego what's up Simone
hey Dr John how are you partying dude
what are you doing
uh not much I haven't had coffee yet so
your enthusiasm is helping me listen I
did it I had I had breakfast with my
buddy who's a physician and even he
after a while was like you gotta stop
man look I had a lot a lot see I'm
pretty wired up good pretty wired
awesome so um I'm I'm
really full that you're taking my call I
love your show and I feel like you have
a way of simplifying things that feel
complicated to people who are in the
issue and so I'm I'm ready to be dazzled
by your Insight I hope I listen it's
simplified because
I'm not that smart and so it has to like
do you remember that that on the office
when that guy was trying to explain what
a um what a profit was and he was like
could you just write this in a crayon
for me like I was a fifth grader that's
me okay so yeah we'll figure it out
that's the kind of help I need I got my
crayons all right let's do it okay great
so my question just to start it off is
pretty much how do I best honor my
husband and son as I continue to endure
like an estrangement that's happening
with my parents they're pretty much not
interacting with me my husband or my
two-year-old little boy
what happened and so I yeah I can give
you the background on that so
essentially what happened is there was
an incident where my mom was like pretty
passive aggressive with my husband stop
it you yeah it happened it's never
happened before in the history of mother
in laws yeah I know I I kid you not it
started with my husband was on the
treadmill and he didn't come and greet
my parents even though they didn't say
when they were coming so it started out
there with like somebody being missed
about him not coming to greet them
because he was on the treadmill getting
a workout so believe it or not that was
the Genesis of all this drama that's of
more than two years restoration so
basically at some point later a couple
weeks later my husband just calls my my
mom out on it and during that two-week
time period She had basically been
coming to me with a lot of complaints
about my husband he's not doing this
he's not doing that and it sort of got
to a point where I just said you know
what I'm not having this you're not
going to talk sh crap about my husband
in his own house right and I need you to
just have this conversation directly
with him and I'm just tired of hearing
about it so she goes in has a
conversation with him he tells her I
didn't appreciate what you did and she
just basically said he didn't mean
anything and he's like well I don't
really believe that I don't believe that
it meant nothing I'm just telling you I
don't want to be disciplined the way
you're going to discipline your own
children and if you have a problem with
me I need you to just come out and say
it directly so essentially my mom took
that to mean that he was calling her a
liar
and it has literally been almost to
going on two years since we've all been
in the same room and talked since then
we've sent Christmas cards I invited
them to my son's birthday my dad didn't
come and then my mom came but she didn't
talk to my husband at all so he just was
the bigger man just went up shook her
hand said Hi how are you doing stuff
like that but even then she said to some
of my sister-in-law and my mother-in-law
that I was being a bad daughter because
I hadn't come and you know healed the
breach and stuff and at this point Dr
John I'm just not really sure I'm not
doing a whole lot to fix the situation
but I feel like there's a lot of things
that are pretty unexcusable about this
some of it is you know my husband is of
African descent he's literally from
Africa so there's his first language is
French not English so we're looking at
racial cultural language we're looking
at a lot of ways where somebody could
have just stepped back and said listen
I'm coming from a different place
different culture different language
maybe I'm just construing this wrong let
me settle down and just get my
perspective on this and let me just go
talk to the man but it's literally been
my dad doesn't talk to me anymore my dad
doesn't talk to my husband they don't
come and see my son and it's been like
this for two years and I'm just like
what is my responsibility
as a daughter who can as always
considered herself to be dutiful but I
just feel like my I have to honor my
husband and my son first
it's hard yeah
I I
don't like and I do it occasionally on
the show and I always kick myself as I'm
walking out of the studio I hate doing
it I don't like talking about people
when they're not here okay
and as you were talking I was asking
myself and I was about to ask you
this thing that happened with the
treadmill
that wasn't what started all of this
there was something that you had done as
daughter
to blow up their pretty little picture
of what their life was going to look
like
and then at the very end you said and I
married a black guy who speaks French
who whatever whatever I'm in
right tell me I'm wrong there
um I don't think you're wrong but to be
honest with you the reality of this has
really hit me since this whole thing
went down okay like you know we had a
beautiful big wedding we you know I
didn't get and maybe this is just me
being dense but I didn't get it like I
didn't get the disapproval nobody had a
direct conversation with me that said I
don't think this is right for you or
these are my considerations it was
always just like in retrospect do you
feel it though do you see it like oh
gosh I missed it in retrospect I
or concerned
like at this point in time the whole
thing is just really disrespectful and I
told my mom when this whole thing kicked
off I said you know I just want you to
talk to my husband and just handle
whatever it is that you guys feel you
have yeah but listen listen you're an
adult bothering you just talk to him
you're acting like an adult and she's
not your dad's not either they're acting
like children
right and
this is a hard simple reality your
parents made their choice
and the choice you have to make is not
how do you fix this because you can't
you're the kid
the choice that you have to make here is
how long am I going to continue to
torture myself and my family
trying to prop up this fantasy that I
wanted of what this thing was gonna look
like and face reality that my parents
are acting like children
they have absolutely no interest in
healing this relationship they have they
have an interest in winning
that's why they're waiting for you to
come crawling back
oh that's how it feels it's not how it
feels it's crazy your feelings are
correct yes yeah and then you start to
feel nuts like my mom seriously is not
gonna yep
yep but it's like it's her first born
grand baby
you know there you go acting like a
rational adult there you go
you and you and your common sense Simone
there right it like
you've got to stop running an algorithm
trying to figure this out because this
math doesn't work
so am I doing the right thing then I'm
basically just keeping it classy I'm not
really I'm not going to start up a
dialogue of conversation because to me
what has to happen is a direct
conversation with my husband first as a
respect thing because basically treating
only him like he doesn't exist is not an
option right so I'm just staying back
I'm like I'm waiting for you to do what
I asked
and I'm just gonna I'm waiting patiently
over here I'm not you know but in the
meantime it's like your whole life
starts to get affected by stuff like
this if there's family events if there's
only only when you allow it right and I
say that with all due respect it does
get it does get affected and you do feel
guilty and you do feel bad and then your
brothers and sisters start to look at
you like dude just call Mom just
whatever and just solve all this
and yeah I've had had that conversation
of course you have and so there becomes
this pressure this would it anytime you
put up a boundary you know people are
gonna challenge it and here's what sucks
for someone like you just I could just
by listening to you you put up a
boundary like at work or when
relationships or what you put it up and
then you're ready for someone to come
try to bang their head against it you're
ready yeah well you don't have a plan
for is when someone walks up and sees a
boundary
and just turns their nose up and walks
the other way
yeah because you don't get that fight
that you're gearing up for
and you don't have like you don't have a
a like a way to dispose of that energy
when no one when they're like I'm not
fighting I'm coming over here you hurt
my feelings
and you're like no you gotta fight and
you're they're like I think I think you
nailed it I mean I'm I'm I'm an army
veteran I
got two different theaters I was in Iraq
I was in Afghanistan and I just I'm like
number one if you have a conflict like
we're not gonna have fist the Cuffs but
let's let's solve this problem so we can
move on yes and then also Life's too
short I've lost people were way too
young I I made it I'm in one piece I
came back from all that chaos yes and
I'm like life is too short it's too
precious to be spending all this time
and energy trying to be right or trying
to make somebody else feel like they're
crappy because they said what they said
it's just it's so not the way I would
handle it and I feel like I'm being
sucked into this like you know you know
General Hospital melodrama
you keep walking in the front door right
stop
okay go to Dawson's Creek dude that's a
way better soap opera that's awesome
like yeah go to that one dude don't go
to General Hospital just don't go in
there anymore and again I know what I'm
saying is hard like I know this has a
ripple effect on Christmases and
thanksgivings and gifts and 529 plans
and I get all of that
yeah your parents have chosen to act
like children
here's no your parents have chosen this
they don't like your husband
yeah they don't like your husband in
their life
and you brought him into their life
and so if they can find any reason for
him to not be in their life they will
execute that plan
period wow
and easy that's like such a good dude Dr
John like of course he was so honoring
of them of course he is you know in
every respect like I know my husband and
father you keep so good you keep trying
to make this about rational sense it's
not it's not it's not you can never you
will never find the thing he did
do you know how many in-laws across the
country would just weep with joy if they
were to walk home to their daughter's
house and their husband was on a
treadmill they would be like
it would be it would be cost for
celebration confetti would fall from
this guy he cares
you can't
um you can't rationalize an irrational
Act
and walking away from your grandson and
your daughter and your son-in-law who
clearly loves his daughter
over a greeting issue that as you
mentioned has racial language cultural
boundaries
right uh barriers if you will
and not immediately seeking to go first
and be like oh man he probably doesn't
know or let me I need to just get over
myself because fill in the blank
whatever
they chose to act like kids and I'm
taking my ball and I'm going home
and they I hate that for you I hate that
for you I hate that for you I hate that
for you you don't deserve that you've
because you laid it on the line they get
to have that attitude problem
all right I hate that for you
the thing you and your husband have to
do is to start asking that scary
question which is what we're going to do
next like what's our life going to look
like and I love
um that's the old Bible verse Man the
the greatest way you can get somebody is
to like cry kindness heaps burning coals
on their head right like I'm I'll keep
inviting you
and if they come to your house and start
a fight or start whatever I'm just gonna
kindly ask you to go because I'm just
not gonna have that here I've seen
enough Conflict for my time I'm gonna
choose to have joy is whenever I
possibly can
all right
I hate that for you but hear me say this
you're not you didn't do a thing wrong
not one thing
and can I say can I say that I'm like
I'm in I'm embarrassed yep like I think
the biggest emotion that I feel like I I
I I think shame is a hard word I don't
know that I own it enough because it's
not me who did it but I do feel very
embarrassed like as a
as a member of the family I feel like it
reflects on me and also you know the way
the way America is today you know
there's so many issues with race and so
many issues with Injustice and I just
feel like if we're supposed to be
representative of the change that we're
trying to see we're an interracial
couple we're supposed to be you know
trying trying to make things better and
then here I have this in my own family
this kind of toxic energy and I'm not
saying it's race motivated but I'm just
saying how can you how can you divorce
that from the conversation I
wouldn't I don't know why you would try
I only remember I I don't know why you
would try but that's you going back to
the fantasy
right that you took this hard step think
it back to your military service
you guys took a hard step in the middle
of a mess
and people tried to kill you for it
right
and then back here you fell in love you
you
um didn't follow the little plan that
mommy had laid out for you you fell in
love you found a great remarkable guy
y'all got married you have kid you're
making a life together
and the chaos ensues
and so it's it's it's again it's I get
your embarrassment one thousand percent
I get your embarrassment I mean no if
stands or buts
um but you can't own that you can't own
that and I want to make one thing
um one note I'm always about go first
when it comes to apologizing when it
goes to asking for forgiveness go first
go first the only time I'm not in favor
of that is when
it will be weaponized and used against
you and and that's in an abusive
situation that's in a gaslighting or
narcissism
narcissistic situation or in a situation
like this when you're dealing with
adults who are actually children in
adult costumes
you going and apologizing and saying I'm
sorry
it will invite a even bigger wave of
this nonsense coming over you and your
family and you and your husband and your
child don't deserve that
so I think you continue to be kind you
continue to say hey uh you're welcome to
come to the birthday party I hope you're
here and they get to con they get to
continue to choose their ego and their
nonsensical stupid Pride over their
daughter and their son-in-law and their
little baby
and I can't imagine when they're 92
years old laying on their deathbed that
they're going to thank God I'm glad we
won that argument and missed 14 years of
our grandson's life we showed them
congratulations everybody golf clap you
won
it's ridiculous someone I'm sorry I'm
sorry